fou fou bar songe du bon la femme au
four au four de la retrouver
faux faux faux certainement la femme
séduit surtout par son gens qui font la
femme apart quelquefois culhat dont 100
ménages
le fait est constatée je crois dans les
liens du mariage
mais quand elle pas pétain
ok l'attaquant manceau a vu la chose me
semble plus grave et je me dis en la
voyant
temps
foot
bonsoir et bienvenue à ce contenu alors
comme d'habitude je vais commencer par
un message aux hommes
il arrive que nous
j'ai des prix tous ceux qui vous aiment
ont la chance de pouvoir vous voir tous
les soirs au théâtre des champs elysées
dans la pièce de jean-claude carrière
l'aide mémoire et vous jane vous avez la
chance de tous les soirs dans les bras
de pierre arditi ong du pot c'est quand
même une attraction masculine ambulante
pierrard dit je trouve et on paie qui a
pété par doit vous avez allumé alors
vous avez des notions du chien quand
même je suis adressé à monsieur
excusez-moi bonnes choses contre le il
était un bon savoir si vous êtes sérieux
mais bien sûr je suis obligé jamais été
aussi serrée berry et mais en revenant
sur endettés rien à voir le sourire tout
le monde mais oui aussi raide dans ma
loge
non non non non non je veux juste qu'on
précise que betty est une chienne lui et
que l'un d'entre nous s'appelle bêtise
de mal à nancy on c'est une synthèse sur
un bonheur bien sûr facilement sa
nouvelle un gentillesse inattendue parce
qu'il ya des mecs qui sont bons et puis
lui il m'a dit si tu traites bûche
t'attrape si toi aussi tu trébuche
t'attrape situe un trou dans le texte de
remplir
que demande le peuple non c'était
l'amour alors moi j'ai les deux heures
bon c'est bien
non non c'est déjà ça si vous avez ça
fait beaucoup rêver valérie expert qui
pourraient influer sur voilà
l'objectif c'est d'arriver à sa
l'arrivée et faire du bouddha on va
essayer d'arriver jusque là alors c'est
du boudin alors ça c'est du sein
belkalem sensible quoi céder 100 gr non
pas du tout nous nous étonnions ne dit
pas ça tombe bien c'est pas grave
bon d'accord la laser alors vous voyez
ici vous avez donc plus haut ici vous
avez du boyau ça c'est du boyau si du
show dernier consciente du tout alors le
vote petit travail va consister à
trouver l'extrémité tenez je vous le
donne tout et détruire c'est sa maman
carla bruni en exclusivité fait du
boudin
elle était terrifiée la charcuterie a
fait une bonne charcutière pour le
moment aucun jeu consiste à considérer
séparément remplir le boyau avec le son
les des gens bien regarder comment vrai
j'aimerais du bouddha est ce que je suis
en train de faire du boudin et est-ce
que vous avez déjà fait du boudin jamais
jamais je n'ai pas du tout que c'était
aussi est ce que vous vous une personne
tu condamnes en voilà des lobbys
attendait a clairement pas ce que la wii
je n'ai pas je vais essayer de nous
parce qu'on va pas en faire pendant deux
heures on va essayer d'en faire un
déjà voilà fait un bouddha ça c'est très
bien
alors là maintenant il faudrait vous
fassiez glissé non non non non non et
encore c'est fragile c'est du boyau
nature
et mis à part ça il faut pas qu'il y ait
de l'ère de la houille ou bien mettez
j'ai déjà fort mais celui là ça fait si
vous voulez remettre un petit feu de 120
métaux du sang des ivoiriens
cet appel à ces brillants n'a pas été
parfait eh ben je crois qu'on va pouvoir
l'arrêter d'un savoir frais du boudin
sinon je serais ouvert ça ça peut se
récupérer doyon était fragile
écoutez moi je trouve qu'on s'en est pas
mal tiré
il
là
ma sphère culturelle pour faire plaisir
à pierre arditi à londres il ya une
exposition de mort de bavent de plus des
diarrhées ces merdeux ce que vous faites
ici dont de diarrhée si vous aimez l'art
contemporain le coaching est à
britannique d' independence vous
conseille d'aller à londres voir cette
exposition magnifique
mais
c'est l'islam est absolument au but à
jordi fête culturelle assez
solennellement que j'allais dans une
émission intelligente donc si vous
voulez ne pas prendre complètement
ridicule l'invitation d'ailleurs donc
c'est une farce et à la soul william de
galles rhys williams gary d vous êtes ya
la williams gary locke est là sous il ya
une galerie vous avez une jeune femme
qui s'appelle laura godfrey isaac qui
trouvent qu'il faut parler un peu plus
souvent de ces matières de ces
substances plus ou moins corporels que
sont le plus là
non mais c'est des tableaux cesson et
tableau alors cessons de tableau joël je
vous ai dit c'est pour vous donc ce sont
des tableaux alors autre chose qu'aux
choses est ce que vous savez pourquoi
l'équipe nationale de côte d'ivoire de
basketball féminin a perdu le
championnat d'afrique
elle avait été à l'exposition intitulée
pourquoi je vais vous dire c'est
l'explication du coup il est au pouvoir
rien notre temps
la contre-performance pour être
émission intelligente à gonesse qui
habitons merde l'heure c'est une cata
comment je suis allé faire profiter de
cet intérimaire de la shdm est né à me
lâche alors on y va
l'ex-maire complètement pierre
bush à le remettre
on regarde pas aucun des trois oui
l'homme d'immigrants venus
et bien va craquer allez on y va allez
on y va
baba comptait aller non non non alors je
vous donne la réponse honnête de match
voit rien le temps la contre performance
sportive pour être introduit soit comme
en asie